but now here's the thing is they love
lucy' wall but particularly that's
because Carey Mulligan you're kind of on
your holidays yeah this is your week off
is yes you're on Broadway you're not
boring now you're here but you want you
know there's a poster off you want
Broadway at the moment yeah so what's
happening there just lights off no one
lights off no one's there I'm here
instead so they're not seeing Bill Nighy
and somebody else no no no Bill's got
bills got an actual holiday okay I've
got this yes look great what great fun
so and you're on board with skylit what
you did here as well in western last
summer I am but I read that you were
saying that American audience is quite
different more vocal yeah bit bit more
yeah get they get involved it's sort of
more like audience participation in
theatre than when I'm used to
wasn't there a lady with very loud voice
in the cooking it was yeah I cook her
spaghetti bolognaise play every night
and I start with the onions and I worked
my way through and there was a very
helpful lady couple of rows back
he's been the entire show commenting on
every ingredient so I'd get the onions
out start chopping she goes oh my god
there's onions all around her be like
yeah and then I get out the you know the
garlic and smush oh my god garlic
um which was distracting but also quite
fun yes go into school yeah the only one
that couldn't see at the back so yeah
this couldn't be more 1977 and it was at
the time when Genesis were at the height
of their fame we were all very excited
understand okay yeah especially if
you're French its ventriloquist dummy is
a talking dog great a dog it's a talking
dog it's a dog it's a talking dog yeah
whatever